je veux la paix dans le monde
je suis pour la peine on où j'ai pour la
paix dans le monde je me présente je
suis actuellement en bts commercial me
sauver la planète j'aime bien m'occuper
des enfants handicapés
j'aime les animaux une gamme de naître
beaucoup d'hommes de ma personne mais
moi ma beauté et douce et extérieurs et
intérieurs toi berne où il faut répondre
sérieusement les pères un lausanne
genève bâle et je derrag est je pense ce
serait qu'il n'y a pas très grand mais
toute évidence pour moi c'est kelly miss
france magnifique très belle kelly
oui seniors ce serait bizarre pour moi
mr et mme p c'est valérie benaïm la
reine de tmp kelly assuré
ce serait moi ce serait moi sans aucun
doute dans le désert parce que le niveau
est faible jean luc lemoine oui il
émerge personnes
mathieu mathieu quoi
mathieu ça peut marcher aussi en
deuxième choix de l'ordre de matthieu
delormeau je fais pas la vérité mais
souffre de monolithes et lui un melon
c'est une pastèque alors ce serait
matthieu delormeau a alors je vais vous
surprendre
c'est plus matthieu delormeau c'est
maxime gainey est encore pire que ce à
quoi les jambières bien qu'à gauche